Reggie Miller Hall of Famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst and it's the annual
fundraiser time for reg as dropping
dimes foundation and he's certainly been
one of the leaders of this on the
forefront of dropping dimes foundation
organization created to assist retired
NBA players who have fallen on hard
times more on that from reg coming up in
a moment
good morning reg who wins tonight
Toronto oh it's over okay it's over
tonight I like I you know we've been on
we've been going back and forth of this
I am as shocked as just about anyone on
how these finals have gone you know I
felt even without Kevin Durant the
warriors especially the way they have
played coming into the finals with the
ball movement
you know Steph had found his groove back
to where you know that first MVP year
and things seemed to be clicking
draymond Green was playing at an
all-time high they were getting
contributions from Kevon Looney so I
felt that they had enough to beat the
Raptors without KD but we were all
surprised and we were all wrong and you
got to give Nick nurse and Kauai and the
Raptors all the credit but I will have a
poll question for McLovin for tomorrow
if let's just say Toronto does win does
San Antonio and I know Toronto is going
to do they retire when it's all said and
done do they retire collided as his
numbers hang from the Raptors Vulcan San
Antonio and Toronto there's only a few
players that have you know to get that
privilege I know Shaq has it I know
Michael Jordan has it in Chicago Miami
well Chamberlain I believe has it with
Golden State and Philly does quite
Leonard have two numbers retired in two
different buildings
how many Raptors have they retired well
if they win yes I think if they haven't
retired Vince Carter's then they haven't
retired anybody's he's still
I'm assuming they he will get retired
maybe Bosch will get retired yeah but
certainly Kauai will get retired first
of all I should be the first to get a
statue I love Vince but Vince didn't
deliver the promised land again it's not
over but we're assuming but if they go
on to win a championship
Kauai should be the first to have a
statue in Jurassic Park I know I do know
that okay how many Spurs have had their
numbers retired Paulie
I got Johnny Moore Avery Johnson Bruce
Bowen James Silas managed nobly Tim
Duncan oh yeah Elliott they're they're
pretty lenient Gervin David Robinson
they're pretty lenient there reg don't
you think quiet
being an MVP of the finals winning a
championship yes but the only reason why
I am that is how they're now well there
would be water under the bridges and
bygones be bygones and
you did deliver us one of our five
championships and yes your number should
be hanging here or will they harbor some
ill will I believe he should have his
number retired in both when it's all
said and done because we consider we
will consider him one of the all-time
greats especially he's highlighted that
in this series and in these playoffs but
you know what though reg I don't think
Kawhi Leonard cares no I don't think
you'll care at all it's not one of those
where you go man it'd be nice if they
honored me I don't think Hawaii's gonna
care I agree that's his nature yeah but
how we were looking for this matchup
between Kauai and Kevin Durant
personally I still don't think Kevin
Durant playing tonight I think this is
from the warrior standpoint I think
they've been always saying oh he'll be
back you know through games three or
four possibly I think they've have been
doing this to kind of tease the Toronto
Raptors a little bit make them go over a
different type of scouting report in
anticipation of him coming back
I don't think and it never fazed Toronto
by the way I just don't think he's
coming back
there's there's no way you can come back
and play
this level of an important game like
Game five a closeout game with your team
with his back to the light I just don't
see him coming back I could be
completely wrong when he could suit up
and we could see him tonight but I just
think the injury at first initially I
thought it was Achilles but yeah
obviously if he's practicing but I just
think that injury the weight again go
back to way he looked back that was that
that told me everything and I just do
not see him playing tonight I hope I'm
wrong Dan I hope I'm wrong but reg I
think they unintentionally did a
disservice to Katie because it felt like
you know what he's close to coming back
in in the houston series or the portland
series and then in this series and then
if it's gonna be the next game and then
it's gonna be the next game I think they
got it instead of just having a blanket
statement saying Katie's not coming back
anytime soon and if he does it'll be a
great bonus for us but we're not
expecting him to come back I don't care
if it you know this the gamesmanship
with Toronto I don't think Toronto is
losing sleep going oh my god now we got
to prepare for him correct and that's
why I just think Golden State you know
they didn't try to do this but I think
the perception publicly is come on Katie
what's wrong with you but I will also
say this could be coming a little bit
from Katie's camp as well because as a
former player who's had an injury and
had to play an important games if I felt
good in the training staff came to me
and says I'm progressing and I feel
pretty good he could be sending out
those messages as well to the coaching
staff and that you know Raymond Ritter's
of the media the PR guys for the for the
Warriors I mean they're taking that as a
greatness all too well Katie says he
feels fine and so they can kind of be
adding a little bit life to the story as
well again I just don't see him playing
tonight because what will he gain from
this if it was to to possibly possibly
but 3-1 and you're going to come back if
anything you should have came back in
Game four you can play
five you could play in Game four I
always thought of things if you could
play in Game five you could have played
in Game four but let's say they win
tonight
with them or without him without him and
then you go back home I would roll the
dice again without him okay and if we
find a way to win that is anything he
would come back for Game seven if
anything to give you that extra you know
push on the road in Jurassic Park in
that building you know but you know what
it's not gonna get to that Toronto's
hoons tonight Toronto in tonight he's
Reggie Miller Hall of Famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst tell the audience
again about the I think this the I'm not
sure how many years you've done this but
it's the annual fundraiser dropping
dimes Foundation and explain what you're
doing this is the third year we're doing
this um I'm a huge as you know cyclist
mountain biker and this is a way for me
to merge both worlds of basketball as
well as cycling the dropping down use
foundation helps ABA players not NBA
it's the old red white and blue ABA
players my good uncle Mel Daniels Roger
Brown God rest their souls you know that
Pacers team they meant everything to the
city of Indiana
now remember when the ABA merged with
the NBA only the really good players
were able to go from the ABA to the NBA
dr. Jay Rick Barry George the Iceman
Gervin so the really good players were
taken from the ABA to play in the NBA a
lot of the ABA players there was no
health insurance obviously back in the
late 60s and 70s they didn't make a lot
of money so a lot of these players who
are well in their you know late 60s 70s
and 80s they've fallen on hard times
they can't even even buy a suit to go
for job interview so what these kits and
jerseys from Castelli Thank You Castelli
cycling for merging and helping with me
do these boom baby kits boom baby comes
from the great Slick Leonard when
you know the Pacers and myself would
make threes the boom baby that's what he
would say on the mic so that's what
these jerseys are about if you love
cycling if you love hiking they're good
for hiking as well because they have
pockets in the back there's a mountain
bike mountain bike jersey as well so
it's a chance for me we got to remember
the guys that paved the way for players
like LeBron and Kobe and qui Kevin
Durant Steph Curry a lot of those ABA
players they laid the foundations for us
and I don't want people to forget about
the ABA players as great as the NBA
years there was other basketball with
great players and that's the American
Basketball Association for door yeah
it's Castelli cycling calm and you'll
learn more information about boom baby
and dropping dimes foundation for they
retired ABA players did you see where
rajon rondo
was talking about the possibility of the
trade with Anthony Davis and what it
meant to those young kids on the Lakers
did you read those comments rent I did
what did you make that once again it's a
mess with the Lakers because you don't I
understand you know the frustration from
the players and the younger players
because they felt everyday they walked
in that they weren't even go and be able
to get into the practice facility
because their code was going to be
denied so you've got young players who
are anywhere from 20 to 25 years old
walking on eggshells with the face of
the NBA and LeBron James and then you've
got a mess in the front office with
magic pálinka Jeannie bus Linda Rambis
Curt ray you don't know what's going on
in the front office so that's why you
know what people continue to say all
this the Lakers are going to be back
this summer um I'm not so quite sure
about that because there are such
turmoil until they figure out the
hierarchy of that franchise in this
snipping you can't have young players
feel look the narrative was you could
have anyone on our team but LeBron James
heisting Alonzo ball Kyle Kuzma Brandon
eat well I
he's got weight wool and you want me to
come out here and play hard and I'm
reading this in the paper you can have
anyone on our team other than LeBron
James
that's terrible management Theodore
terrible yeah and I know that you're
supposed to be a grown-up and you
understand it's a business it's still
understand the reality of your idol you
know where it's hey I'm playing with
LeBron James
wait LeBron wants to have me traded
these guys had his shoes his posters
they idolized playing with him but on
the flip side they okay I'm not gonna
put it all on LeBron but he is the de
facto face of the of the Lakers right
he's the voice yes he could be like this
is not happening no don't do this he
could have come out publicly yeah I I
just I I think what Rondo was saying we
assumed but you know then to try to kind
of go okay I didn't get traded let's
just move forward with this and I'm
gonna somehow put my heart and soul out
there on the line for this guy who once
is traded oh now he's injured now we're
the ones playing here I don't know it
just it's a weird dynamic even though
you're paid to be a professional and
this is part of the territory of being a
professional of the possibility getting
traded that would be pretty difficult
for me if all of a sudden the guy that I
collected his shoes and had his poster
and now I'm playing with him and wait he
wants us all traded it's very
frustrating especially for a young
player and I think Rondo being the true
professional he's been and being in
situations rumor this he was the young
lad in Boston when it was cagey Paul
Pierce Ray Allen so he was that young
lad that was trying to learn from the
vets and understand and he learned the
right way right and ended up winning the
championship and think about all the
places he's been since then Dallas
Sacramento he's seen so much in this
league from veterans because he's won
now two young players and being on young
teens he understands this ain't right
this is not how things are done this is
not
like this you don't put people's dirty
laundry for an iconic franchise like the
Lakers you cannot have your dirty
laundry just hanging out there for
everyone to see you just can't do that
go to the website Castelli cycling
dot-com slash us men's collection boom
baby and it's a register on razor third
year that you've done this all the
profits benefit the dropping dimes
foundation an organization created to
assist retired ABA players who have
fallen on hard times registered on top
of value I batch it as well so whatever
the total sales is I match it as well so
please buy as many Broome baby jerseys
as possible because we I get to match it
and it's it's an even bigger pot for
these great ABA pioneers Thank You reg
you're the best Theodore thank you I
love y'all get ready for the Bruins and
st. Louis for the finals okay per game
thank you rich got reg doing hockey to
reg Miller Hall of Famer Turner Sports
NBA analyst for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]